REQUESTED IT BE AT HOME.
HETROUBLE TURNOVER-WISE EARLY F
THE SHAR TEAM BEHIND
TROY TERRY
COMES UP TO THE BLUE LINE, AND
THOUGH, NET WHERE THE WATER
BOTTLE IT, WELL-PLAC IT, BUT
MAHURA JUST GETS IT AWAY IN
TIME STARTED
WORKING FOR THE D THEYF TROY TES
WITH A STICK OR NOT.
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK. BEING
REVIEWED
DIDN'T SAY WHAT  TERRY'S
STICK, ONTO THE SAN JOSE STICK
AND THTHV.
WATCHED BY ZEGRAS.
FERRARO TOS IN
MAHURA GETA SHOT, OVER THE NET
IT CURLS ALL THECK IN FRONT, OFE
STICK OF SIMON
WON'T BEAL AND THEY TERRY
SEEN HIM PROGRESS THIS SEASON,
WHEN HE MAKES A  LINE, SLAP PASS
FOR JOSHT A PIECE OF THE STICK T
THERE. UP
TOP FOR MEGNA, SHOT BLOCKED BY
ZEGRAS, COMES RIGHT BACK TO
MEGNA ANOF THE AIR AND WHA
HE'S PUT DOWN BY DRYSDALE.
JAMIE DRYSDALE WITH
GADJOVICH.
JONAH.
GREGOR, TO BURNS, OFF THS BLOCK.
JOSH COMING OUT BEING
AGGRESSIVE AND MAHURA PICK
TIME, LOVE SAYING THATO
KNOWS WHAT THEY'LL GET IN THE
DRAFT  FOR 5-2
STOLARZ GETS THE PUCK, GOT TIME,
UP